I'm bad at putting like my stand-up
clips
into a place where people can just like
look at them and bite size and like
review them it's like really it's my
biggest it's crazy right now and it's
it's the biggest problem for me I it's
the thing I'm best at without question
out of all the things that I do is stand
up because I've been doing it the
longest not because I'm like you know
it's just the thing that I have the most
hours accumulated towards doing and I'm
so critical of it that I can put even
putting out a special is hard for me I
like stand up because I originally got
into it because you just do it and then
it's over yeah and people can go I
remember that joke sucked and you go but
didn't yeah because it's just your
memory it's gone but now you can go back
and look and for me it's never good
enough yeah and so when I watch us and
I'm so critical of stand up already and
people not being as good as I want them
to be and people like I just I'm so
critical that I think people are as
critical of me and so I don't put any
Clips out because I'm just worried that
people will finally figure out I'm not
as talented as like maybe I'm trick
people into being like that imposter
syndrome which everyone [ __ ] has feel
like that about your specials though yes
really they're not like I it takes me my
HBO special which I'm proud of it just
like you know it's one night of your
life and my stand-up is not like
scripted to a t there my special perfect
the first one I put out was pretty
scripted to a t it was more early on
when I wasn't doing as much like not
storytelling but just riffen and since
then my style is just I get up there and
I say the joke differently every single
time and usually you'll find a place
where it works but I like to just like I
was saying before I like to be in the
moment I like it to be honest so I hate
when it's scripted and so yeah that one
night in Denver when I saw the special
like
I don't know I was just feeling a little
bit too like there was just things about
both my performances that night and I go
why did you say the joke like that you
never even said it like that why would
you do and I'm like and you missed that
one line that you could have like
there's so many deep regrets so that
special in particular came out in July
and I am very proud of it in the end I
was like oh this is good but I was so
scared to look at it and I wanted I had
to edit it because I couldn't trust
anyone else to do it that it was
supposed to come out in March and I had
to come out in July because I could not
look at it I couldn't watch it I can't
watch myself editing yourself is tough I
also think the tough part was stand up
like when you film specials too is it's
like such a fine line that when you get
all that production in the room it just
changes the vibe yes you know and it's
just it it does it's hard I think
to focus on what you came there to do
that too yeah and then the audience
likes they see all the gear and [ __ ]
yeah the audience can't relax and that's
what I was saying before you need to
make them relax in order to have a good
show for them to laugh you can't laugh
when you're like like super nervous and
anxious and so I learned my next special
and I think you know if you're smart
you'll steal this as any comedians
listening uh don't have an opener go out
and open your own show and get relaxed
and go listen this is a taping I'm
nervous you're nervous who gives a [ __ ]
we're all gonna die like have a moment
with them where it's like they're not
rolling this is so wrong to nothing lock
the door
you break out the gun
but like I'm gonna open my next special
because I just wish I would have had
that moment with them to be like guys
this is like just I'm a little bit on it
because like I watch it now I'm like oh
you're a little bit nervous and I never
get nervous on stage but when it's a
taping and there's HBO and sex there and
like my friends and family are there of
that [ __ ] and I don't and I don't want
them there next time yeah that adds
another layer to it I just want to be
comfortable and the best specials I feel
like are the are the guys are gals I
call them gals uh that are just you know
comfortable and you can just you can
just sense nerves even if you don't if
you watch someone you go they're not
nervous there's a part of your
subconscious that's like I can tell
they're nervous so I'm just laughing at
someone taking that sentence out of
context being like Nikki Glaser said
only men's specials are the best
when guys do specials it's so good
sorry what are you gonna say I was gonna
say I do I do like it seems to be a
little not a little bit of a trend right
now where people will put their specials
out on YouTube but they'll like spend
less on production so
and they'll shoot it at a smaller venue
so it seems more intimate like a little
bit more natural it's just kind of like
you're watching as a viewer it's like oh
I'm just watching like as if I were
there it's not like this big ass show
it's the best in a 200 cap room that's I
feel like anything over 200 I know all
the best rooms are 200 you know that's
interesting yeah in terms of clubs I
don't know theater's still running
[ __ ] good yeah theaters are fun I
mean that feeling what I like yeah yeah
it could be really fun I love Norm
McDonald's playing Stadium
playing stadiums is really cool too have
you ever yeah
I've never heard of them
I think MSG personally was the best
performance that we did yeah
um the pillai in Melbourne you ever done
that
I uh yeah we haven't done stadiums by
the way I just no I know okay okay
that's why she's laughing
[Laughter]
[Music]
McDonald's special where he's just in
front of his computer his last one you
know before he died there's no audience
and I'm like thank god let's skip the
laughter I don't need to be coached to
laugh sometimes I'm just like I watch
specials on two times the speed because
I'm like just I want to hear jokes I I
can laugh on my own time and I don't
need you know but that that laughter
actually I mean laughter does it's
contagious and so it does like teach you
what's funny and what's not but I really
liked just like Bare Bones just like I
sometimes just want to read jokes I just
put the captions on I'm like I just want
to like see I don't need to hear someone
I don't need the audience to be like
yeah
um but I have no patience dude I want to
put out a special so it's gonna be like
a live Journal post yeah please watch
the [ __ ] out of it yeah this is no no
there's no crowd like you just read it
or you're like I mean like would you
like watch yeah Tick Tock are reals like
stand up do you unmute it do you no I do
that actually I do watch people's yeah I
watch side captions yeah same they're
like in bed yeah if they even wake up
and if she's not awake yet I'll just
like turn on the volume all the way down
and then I'll watch it that that way you
can watch everything with the captions
and I don't really need sound anymore I
just you know what I'm gonna do a bunch
of anti-comedy stand-up Clips where I
just say one word and the remaining 59
seconds is just people laughing that's
just me gloating yeah yeah so uh I'm not
kidding you people would actually that's
actually happening where people say no
joke yeah and I just I wait for it I
wait for the joke and I'm like how does
this have ms3
[Laughter]
you should you should film your special
and then put it out but the volume
mixing is really bad yeah you just can't
hear your joke you're telling jokes what
the audience laughter is way too loud
the whole time okay like throughout like
just constant laughter through the whole
thing
and then all the ads are like back to
back laughs
non-stop laughter yeah cause that what
that's a terrible show the crowd Can't
Get Enough
air
I'll kill myself now uh are you on the
road a lot
uh I've been this year you have been
yeah is it uh and how old are you
14. I'm uh everyone should commit
suicide because I'm literally you're
married yes oh wow how is that for your
relationship it's fine she's good yeah
she's totally down she's cool about it
yeah she's uh it's funny like really
early on like when we started touring
um Japanese you're Japanese no that's
right let's try let's try that's true I
don't know you just picked up your cap
and I was like I see yeah because of the
way I yeah that's a little racist you
just looked like someone who I think
might be Japanese I don't know
she's like you've seen Indiana Jones
right
I don't know no yeah she's she's good
with it um that's nice it's hot because
it's nice though because you go away a
lot and then you you miss them well
early on when we started touring like we
figured out pretty quickly touring is
not glamorous and like
they they came out like both of our
partners they came out to like some butt
[ __ ] city right and it was like all
right yeah this is you know yeah they're
not like oh he's not living the high
life out here yeah I mean you know
sometimes it can be nice but yeah my
wife she had she was working like in
marketing at the time so like when she
would come out she was like I'm not
going to [ __ ] I'm not I'm not going
to St Louis for the weekend yeah yeah I
mean I lived there so that was rude but
I'll be there next year it's not wrong
oh that's awesome I was there earlier
this year I'm there uh New Year's Eve
I'm doing a big theater there the
steeple so funny we're listeners I'm on
tour right now
um started again and uh going to Memphis
tomorrow and like sales are like real
[ __ ] low I saw I saw the the bit you
did yeah it's embarrassing you just
gotta like I hate singing to him she's
like yeah I wrote a song about like you
know I took that song that's like
Walking in Memphis so I was just like
did a song about how it's so good I love
that song what's the artist get his name
post Malone no yeah
but I redid it and I was just talking
about people coming to my show but you
know because my agents are like please
put out like some video getting people
to please come yeah Mark Cohn yeah yeah
do you have any other hits I wonder
um running in Vegas
[Laughter]
it's a little bit faster it just does
all different
um but yeah it uh I I did this video but
it was just like I just hate doing any
kind of video of like come see my show
everyone like it's just so tired and I
kind of just want to be honest of like
tickets aren't selling well there it
doesn't hurt my feelings because I'm
selling well everywhere else so like one
city it's not like this is desperate but
it's like this city I like Memphis and I
would like to go back but if you don't
sell well the first time you come
through it's like yeah probably won't go
back so I was telling him that I feel
like the thing after covet is everyone's
so last minute yeah and they are and
with stand up I feel like you have to be
telling people to the date so you're
like I'm in it's so funny and then you
get people afterwards they're like oh
[ __ ] I didn't know you were here no I
know how did you not know I know